further the living substance is being
which is in truth subject or what is the
same is in truth actual only insofar as
it is the movement of positing itself
whereas the mediation of its self
uttering with itself this substance is
as subject pure simple negativity and is
for this very reason the bifurcation of
the simple it is the doubling which sets
up opposition and then again the
negation of this in different diversity
and of its antithesis the immediate
simplicity only this self restoring
sameness or this reflection into in
other nests within itself not an
original or immediate unity as such is
the true it is the process of its own
becoming the circle that presupposes its
end as its goal having its end also as
its beginning and only by being worked
out to its end is it actual
and section 17 as we've seen Hegel
insisted that we need to understand
substance and by this we're gonna see he
means these substance as subject as not
being something inert but rather as
being something active something dynamic
and then the question is what does that
really mean how does this work and
that's what section 18 is leading us
into you see I've got to sort of scheme
up here on the board with a number of
Hegel's terms before we go into that
what is this this section completely
focused on the question of truth what is
the truth of a substance we're not of
substance itself of these substance
truth is not going to be what he calls a
primal original or simple unit that
doesn't mean that it's going to lack
unity altogether but what it means is we
need to rethink what unity what actually
being one thing means
and here we're grappling with terms that
are quite difficult it may seem to be
very simple to you until you start
thinking about them they're sort of like
Augustine when he talks about if
somebody asked me what before somebody
asked me what time is I know perfectly
well what it is as soon as somebody asks
me about it
now I'm not quite so sure it becomes
murkier and murkier upon analysis it
works the same way with terms like truth
or unity these are actually what in in
medieval theology and philosophy they
called the transcendentals and Hegel is
grappling with these sorts of things
what is the truth what it or what is the
true what is truth per se what is unity
what is being what is goodness and
there's property no the proposals to
have other things as transcendentals
that's a whole little different
conversation but I think that's
important to bring up here at the start
so Hegel says the truth of substance
is that it's also a subject and what
does that really mean that means that it
exists or it has its being in it what he
calls positing setting forth this is
what we call a thesis setting forth
itself that is to say that it's it's
actively pushing itself out into reality
it's not just something sitting there
your nerves so he says it is in truth
actual and only insofar as the movement
of positing itself or is the because of
another term mediation of its self
uttering with itself so what that means
is that for a subject or a substance
whichever way we want to look at it the
way it puts itself forward is as itself
and yet at the same time as something
other than itself as something different
from itself and you might say what is it
like splitting into two in a certain way
it is and we'll talk about that but this
is a splitting into that takes place
within the thing itself within its own
movement it becomes other to itself and
only by doing so can actually be fully
what it is supposed to be only in this
way does it have the possibility of
dynamism of activity if we want to look
at the ahead to a few other paragraphs
that are coming up of purpose of
activity of rationality all of these
things for Hegel require that it undergo
what he calls me VA ssin in German this
is from Midland so when you see this
term media think middle also think as
we're going to see in another very
important paragraph later on also think
the the medium in which something takes
place but think middle term like the
middle term of a
an argument or syllogism as well think
about what it was that that was
originally allowed intended to do which
is to connect up to things which are not
the same and bring them into relation to
each other
mediation is going to be a key concept
for haggling and going ahead a few
paragraphs we're gonna we're gonna look
at that in a bit more detail here he's
just sort of naming it introducing it so
he says the substance is as subject so
if we're talking about this kind of
being this mode of being as subject he
says it is pure simple negativity now
there's nothing simple about this
negativity because what does it mean to
negate it means to say no it means to
say there's something else it means to
say not that so already there is other
or alterity involved in negation and so
it puts itself forward and yet at the
same time also negates itself without
losing itself without just vanishing
without disappearing so it's doing two
things at the same time it's becoming
complex so it says he says it is for
this very reason the bifurcation of the
simple what's simple splits and you know
if we want to use a very simple schema
here I understand simple is a little bit
of a pun you've got what's being
positive and then you have what is being
put forth as know as something other as
something else which is a negation of
that that's why he talks in terms of
antithesis here so he says it's the
doubling which sets up opposition and
then again the negation of this
indifferent diversity and its antithesis
now what he means by antithesis there is
you have a positing so a thesis then you
have something else and then you have
the
antithesis between them so perhaps I
should put this on the board because a
lot of times people get this idea that
he go is all about this try annex truck
sure that's the same in every case where
you have thesis antithesis synthesis and
that these are always identifiable so we
have our subject substance and we have
positive or thesis and at the same time
we have communication we have the the
other which is also being put forward at
the same time as what this substance is
these are different from each other now
between these we have an antithesis we
have a being set at odds with each other
that's literally what antithesis means
so what is going on here the subject is
also at the same time overcoming that
very antithesis of saying yeah you just
have these two things that are sort of
arbitrarily connected with each other
and they're different and that's it and
it's saying no the difference here
really matters this is something that
has to be explored something that has to
be worked out and so that he goes on and
he says only the self restoring sameness
this entire process self restoring
sameness this is where if you want to
you know bring up Hegelian terms you
could say synthesis is actually taking
place only this is the true the true is
not something simple the true is
something that is complex that means
it's not just composed of a bunch of
symbols you know into some sort of
complex but rather is the relation
between all of these moments within this
process that is what truth is so he says
it's the process of its own becoming the
circle that presupposes its end as its
goal having
and also as its beginning and only by
being worked out fully does it become
fully actual now that's where the
paragraph ends I think one of the things
that you want to keep in mind as you're
reading through this is that terms like
actual like true have a certain kind of
relativity to them not any relativism
but a certain kind of relativity to what
stage in the process we're currently
looking at at each each phase in the
phenomenology so when he says that only
by going through through this process of
reintegration does truth really become
actual he's not saying that there's no
actuality before that no reality no
Berkeley Kincaid he is saying that you
have something new something greater
something that's more true something
that's more actual coming on the scene
and it's not something that was totally
new in the sense of not being there at
all
it just wasn't worked out fully
thus the life of God and divine
cognition may well be spoken as a dis
porting of love with itself but this
idea sinks into me ratification and even
in solidity if it lacks the seriousness
the suffering the patience and the labor
of the negative in itself that life is
indeed one of untroubled equality and
unity with itself for which other Ness
and alienation and the overcoming of
alienation are not serious manners but
this in itself an abstract universality
in which the nature of the divine life
to be for itself and so to the self
movement of the form are altogether left
out of account if the form is declared
to be the same as the essence than it is
if so facto a mistake to suppose that
cognition can be satisfied with the in
itself or the essence but can get along
without the form that the absolute
principle or absolute intuition makes
the working out of the former or the
development of the latter superfluous
just because the form is as essential to
the essence as the essence is to itself
the divine essence is not to be
conceived and expressed merely as
essence that is as immediate substance
or pure self contemplation of the divine
but likewise as the form and in the
whole wealth of the developed form only
that is it conceived and expressed as an
actuality
paragraph 19 is another one of those
famous passages that contains what you
might call a galleon catchphrase that is
the discussion of the seriousness the
suffering the patience and the labor of
the negative what's all that about so he
starts off by saying that the life of
God so we're talking about the divine
substance that which is most real the
life of God divine cognition the process
of God thinking God coming to know
things can be understood as love just
sporting with itself a play of love with
itself it's called love squared and he
says that's a that's not a bad idea
that's not a bad conception for
understanding what I'm talking about but
it's going to sink into me ratification
you remember edification is always a bad
thing for Hegel and even being insipid
being tasteless actually lacking wisdom
too because there's you know if you look
at the Latin net connection if it lacks
the seriousness the suffering the
patience of the labor labor of the
negative now those are not things that
you would normally attribute to the
divine except for maybe the seriousness
the the suffering the patience the labor
God is you know completely am nipa tenth
if we're thinking about you know
traditional Jewish Christian Muslim
conceptions of God so why would God have
to suffer why would God have to labor
now with Christianity gets a little bit
different right and you have people
engaging in reflections of why God
became man like like saying in song I'm
gonna set that aside for the moment
why is negativity important so Hegel
talks about the in itself in itself
God or the divine substance that's also
subject is rather static everything is
just fine it's just sort of like a
picture play you might say it says
lacking this this this negative
that life is one of untroubled equality
and unity with itself it's got this sort
of revelation to itself that just
repeats over and over again nothing
changes
it's all just great but what's really
needed is an engagement with other Ness
and alienation now this the very notion
that this is on the scene shows you that
this can't be the whole show other nests
this becoming other that we saw in the
last paragraph going beyond that
alienation alienation means becoming
other to oneself realizing that one is
not what one thought one is that one is
you know anguish idli split over things
you know we saw this we'll talked about
a little bit earlier with those passages
about the New Age that we're in where
spirit has come to realize that it's
lost touch with itself if all you have
is this play of love or God or knowledge
or whatever it is with itself over and
over again but this stuff doesn't really
matter but the fact that this is
actually there at all means that it does
matter
and that over here we're kind of hiding
from from reality hiding from ourselves
and really what has to happen is this
movement of self uttering reflection
into self of splitting of alienation and
then there has to be only on that basis
can there be an overcoming a sublation
a sublimation of this alienation only
after you've actually acknowledged it
you know think about any any given
problem only after you acknowledge that
there's a real problem there can you
actually
with the problem can you actually see it
for what it is can you actually feel its
weight and start to sound its deaths so
he says this in itself is abstract
that's the problem it's abstract
universality but the nature of the
divine is to be for itself the nature of
any subject of anything that actually
thinks anything that knows that takes
the position is at least at a certain
level of reflexivity is to be for itself
to be able to take a position on itself
and in doing so beings often find out
that they aren't what they thought they
were in the first place that there is
other Ness there is alienation taking
place the expectations are are not met
and have to be you know rethought and
then there has to be a process of
reworking this so he talks about this is
the nature of divine life because think
about it if it's if it's God if it's the
absolute the absolute really needs to be
everything that it can be so the self
movement of the form it's left out of
the kettle's now why does this matter
well Hegel is going to talk about
something else at this point he's going
to leave this notion of the form on the
table so this Andy's going to explore
the relationship between form and
essence normally start with essence
normally when we think about the essence
of the thing we think about what it is
that makes that thing that thing and we
have a tendency to think of essences and
sort of static conceptions that we can
grasp and then you know we've got some
sort of copy of that in our head or you
know there may be other relations in
which we we think about our knowledge of
it but we grasp the essence if we're
really
we can actually come up with a
definition that expresses the essence
and that definition better not change
over time better stay the same and the
essence better stay the same over time
Hegel is actually critiquing that very
notion he's not just saying to by the
way well why can't it change over time
he's actually saying it does change
there's a process involved so you'll
actually talk about what's as what's
essential to the essence this may it may
throw you you can say well essences
essence isn't the sort of thing which
can actually be squared which can be
taken to a higher power but why not if
we're doing metaphysics we can actually
say okay you've got essences out there
what's actually essential to essences or
to the notion or you know the the the
being of essence itself what's essential
to that and for Hegel the answer is
actually that it has a form that is
dynamic that is development that it has
a history that it has a before and after
that it has a process of becoming other
and then recovery of that so he says if
the form is declared to be the same as
the essence then it's a mistake by that
very nature to suppose that cognition
can be satisfied with the in itself or
the essence what we want is not just
some sort of you know static stay the
same
anchor point we want to know how the
essence actually plays out think about
some of the conception like freedom now
you can come up with a definition of
freedom and even if you get other people
to accept that definition you need to
actually have examples you need to be
able to talk about the development of
freedom in time in history in situations
for it to really make sense
for one to say yes you've grasped the
essence of it the essence is not a
verbal formula for Hegel so he says that
you thought can't really be happy with
the in itself or the essence but but
getting along without the form the
absolute principle or absolute intuition
makes the working out of this integral
to the very process so if we're talking
about divine cognition not just human
cognition but divine cognition it's
going to incorporate this process this
circular actually cycloidal process of
getting closer and closer and closer to
what's really essential stripping things
away adding things in incorporating
things that's the process of the
dialectic that's what he's describing
here so he says only then when we
actually think of things in terms of the
wealth of form only then is the absolute
conceived and expressed as an actuality
now he is talking about things other
than the absolute because those are all
parts for Hegel of the absolute they're
all moments within the absolute but he
was also talking about the entirety the
whole so he's carrying out a kind of
logical analysis here
the true Miz the hole but the hole is
nothing other than the essence
consummating itself through its
development of the absolute it must be
said that it is essentially a result
that only in the end is it what it truly
is and that precisely in this consists
its nature that is to be actual subject
the spontaneous becoming of itself
though it may seem contradictory that
the absolute should be conceived
essentially as a result it needs little
pondering to set this show of
contradiction in its true light the
beginning the principle or the absolute
is that first immediately enunciated it
is only the universal just as when I say
all animals this expression cannot pass
for a zoology so it is equally plain
that the words the divine the absolute
the eternal etc do not express what is
contained in them and only such words in
fact do Express the intuition as
something immediate whatever is more
than such a word even the transition to
a mere proposition contains a becoming
other that has to be taken back or as a
mediation but it is just this that is
rejected with horror as if absolute
cognition were being surrendered when
more is made of mediation that in simply
saying that it is nothing absolute and
is completely absent in the absolute
paragraph 20 is one of these where he's
drawing some threads together and tying
them in a knot and getting ready to move
on to some some new ideas so he talks
about the true and he says the true is
the whole and then we want to ask well
what the hell does that mean the true is
is the whole it's one thing to talk in
terms of like well you know you gotta
grasp things holistically and take
everything yet for Hegel it's not just
going to be well you know you don't want
to leave anything out it's rather when
we ask this question how how is the
truth the whole it's a question of
essence as he says consummating itself
through development now I wrote a couple
other words under this consummating
because I want us to think in terms of a
few other related concepts that are
connected with this both at Hegel's
thought and also in more you know the
tradition that he's he's working off of
so talk about something consummating
itself particularly to talk about an
essence consummating itself what does
that mean
you know I've brought this up in other
places Aristotle in the politics talks
about the fuzes the nature of the thing
and he says well the nature of the thing
is what that thing is when it's fully
developed when it's fully unfolded when
it's been brought to its perfection and
this is very similar to what Hegel's
talking about so a human being for
example or a horse horse is less complex
than a human being because it's not a
rational animal and reason it doesn't
you know make things simpler to actually
like complicates the hell out of things
including what kind of beings we are
because only rational beings actually
ask what kind of being am i what is what
is my essence that's something that has
to be worked out that has to be in these
emphasized different sort of aspects of
it unfolded when you unfold something
you're pulling something out of it here
you're finding the the the recesses of
it and bringing them to light so that
that sort of puts the stress on the
activity there the perfecting what is
the goal what is the end what is the the
you know finish state that we're talking
about here that the things tend towards
through their processes of development
provided the development is going the
right way that's what we're focused on
here that's how the true is the whole
because the whole ends up being
consummated through this this very
complex process of development that's
going to take place through all of human
history all of human culture coming to a
culmination in of course Hegel we might
want to you know say he might have been
a little optimistic about that but let's
see where he's going so he says the the
nature of the absolute is to be actual
to be subject that to be the spontaneous
becoming of it something he says it may
seem contradictory that the absolute
should be conceived as a result rather
than being was just the starting point
but the absolute is something that
actually has to develop over time and
now he's going to make an analogy here a
really interesting one and he's going to
make a number of different analogies
that lead us into some some you might
call actually logical exercises that
show us what we're supposed to be
grasping here so he says when I say all
animals this doesn't pass for a zoology
similarly when I use words like the
divine the absolute the eternal they
don't actually express what's contained
in them we have to unfold or unpack
what's actually in those it's not
evident from the start what exactly they
comprise and our initial ideas about it
may turn out and in generally in Hegel's
case do turn out to be mistaken turned
out to be starting points that we have
to surpass and surpass and surpass and
also sort of bring along with
so he says whatever is more than such a
word even the transition to a mere
proposition contains a becoming others
so as soon as we start saying something
like the absolute you know we can pick
predicates that we want to say it what
does the absolute mean the absolute
let's say we say develops here in the
subject here we have a predicate already
this this term develops is starting to
sort of color our notion of the absolute
we now have additional information now
you could say well you know the whole
idea of develops was contained in the
absolute if you can see that from the
start just like you know Thomas Aquinas
said you know if you really understand
what what the term God means you'll see
that necessary being is being as is uh
already sort of packed in there he says
this by the way on the commentary on the
salt Hegel would say look when you're
viewing that the predicate is modifying
the way in which you see the subject is
actually making it more concrete more
rich it's no longer just this abstract
thing so he says what's going on here is
the process of becoming other the
predicate mediates the subject the
subject mediates the predicate they they
actually develop the development
develops and then he says a lot of
people don't like that he says this is a
mediation and he says it's just this
that is rejected with horror as if
absolute cognition were being
surrendered
whenever more is made of mediation than
simply saying it's nothing absolute and
completely absent in the absolute
mediation
is going to be integrally present
unavoidable in the very not just concept
but the very reality of the absolute and
its it's process of development is going
to take place through a number of
different mediations